good afternoon chess world on Perry
Colson from the Chess Club this is Tony
Chen we're gonna hear hear to play the
people so get your challenges in we
asked that the are five minutes are
under and they're all rated games and
just get your challenges in and we'll
play the people
Tony Chen is one of our directors of
scholastics and he's here to help me out
so get those challenges in and let's
have some fun playing chess so tonight
is the Friday night action quads come on
down and test your skill against players
of your own level it's the way it works
is it's four people per quad and you
play with each opponent one time and at
the end of the tournament whoever masks
the most points wins $36 so it's pretty
fun it's awesome looking forward to it
hope to see a lot of people come this is
actually my first time being on
livestream so I'm super excited and I'm
gonna start heckling Perry here he's
gonna try to give me some some
suggestive moves so get those chairs
those challenges usually that's the
challenges by now where are those
challenges come on where are you risk oh
come and challenge us
so this crisco started calling now so do
what I do
casual sorry has to be rated Lord of
doom it's gotta be rated ya know casual
games oh we don't do anything casual no
casual around here so come on off and go
and go rated we'll play I don't know if
I should put this out there though
you're not really playing some lifetime
master here you're just playing me so
keep that in mind and come on get those
get those challenges in everybody's
scared I like how you called out Risto
just by name I did go on you just want
to call I want okay I want Nick risk oh
so Nick if you're out there come on Nick
he's calling you out come on I'm calling
you out no challenges alright I know
they're not scared of me what's your
rating
oh my blitz rating is only like nine
nine nine ninety-five all right there
you go Lord of doom good job all right
let's do this five-minute game all right
900 play here we go all right here we go
your move Lord of doom
ok I like it although alright not have
six please okay names Oh Indians that
we're going with looks that way
we're play the chord and play the Queens
the Queen's Indian defense though yeah
all right I like it taketake Grandmaster
Dennis Borel showed me this position one
time well I can get to the position and
then sometimes it falls apart but we're
gonna do our best
Wow your uh since you were trained by
Dennis Broyles on this opening weekend a
premature soom that is solid it's solid
but again I can get there but just
finishing it off because trouble
something from time to time but we're
gonna get this Queen to c8
and then we're gonna play a c5 and I
think it's a pretty solid opening you
heard him he's playing a c5 next I am
playing c5 next make it accordingly
c5 next make you well maybe not now well
he played you takes that so so we can
just push this guy right here so a lot
of time so you know yeah I start taking
my time and it's bad if I do that okay
tonight you just trapped your night
brother
you trapped your night Lord all right
but we're okay we're okay we are okay
doubling up the Brooklyn Queen I love it
mm-hmm basic you know basic tactical
move
all right
what's this guy what's this he's 562
something like that Wow attack us should
we attack his queen I think you should
attacking us you know a good office is a
good defense the defense is a good
offense a good offense is a good defense
there we go always attack that's my
that's basically what I do I'm trade
hack people he can take mine I take his
but then I get his like maybe I'll give
his back we'll see see what happens see
you what let's do it let's do oh he took
he took him he took my stuff yeah so if
I take he attack you now you should
attack him back right if I take here
though and he takes my queen I can win a
piece is that what he's gonna do well
you sure I just took this know it's
gonna be even even is he gonna take you
up on it looks like you did you did take
my pawn will play right here see what
happens about your other pond where
other pond hanging no it's not really
hanging
thank you're good gonna push that yeah
what I see five boom I totally flaked
see five eventually
aggressive-aggressive
somebody uh somebody on YouTube well
they got is well they're saying he's
saying a sick spawn that's all he said
hey six Papa talk until you have my
opponent it already died died a horrible
death
it's died a horrible death let's look at
a situation right now how you yeah cuz
this guy's hanging a little bit hmm yeah
without me you have to do something
about that guy like it like it got do
something about your f rook man I don't
get him and live up to get him in the
ball game
yeah right now you're playing with one
rook yeah that's gonna be good that's
not bad
oh no I'm gonna lose another pawn no you
got you got a little you get you could
do a dish up take some which it takes
what it sure takes a h right here to
lose a part lose it lose official if he
if he takes your your your pawn you got
a little you know some kind of discovery
[Laughter]
Nicholas what's you say what's risk are
you thank you for all the help
moderating all the chats you know it's
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
Lord of doom skimmer it to us
you gotta do a bit better bro yeah try
it I don't see you doing it haven't you
rut have any more 55 it away I didn't
pay attention to them okay well let's
get him in the game are you gonna play
d8 again wrote the date again
down by what two pawns now you gotta
catch up man
okay I'm gonna try we just start taking
some bets here who's really who thinks
Perry's gonna play I do not mean ones
that not me and down on time you never
know your opponent can always make a
mistake at this level it's definitely
possible his rating was what 15 - 9 95
so yeah it's doable it's doable got a
little try going on backward you know
get get your King off that white white
square diagonal to getting 10
looks like he's trying to do the to pawn
advantage over there oh he's a bad shape
here but we're gonna try to get out of
it somehow
come on Terry
what are we doing here what are we doing
takin's rook okay
don't you do something about that pawn
majority on the other side both sides he
has a paw majority let's get rid of that
skill how we gonna do that
um you have yellow I don't know we'll
see
yeah good rook placement boom-boom I
like it I like it
yeah all right get y'all your pawns up
there oh now your kings a little little
bi open a little open that's cool all
right I like how his rook is kind of
stuck on over there whoa all right all
right
I'll work on the F file all right I
don't they interesting try anything once
I thought you were originally going to
go there from the beginning it's cool up
now he's taking advantage of the
opportunity we're gonna do we're gonna
do oh you're in a little trouble here Oh
big trouble a lot of trouble and time
trouble too mm-hmm time trouble too you
guys think he's gonna win on his his
opponent went on times bad war checkmate
it's bad probably on time it at this
time because it's about 20 almost twenty
four seconds that's bad
Oh oh what a train he's got a pond there
yeah that's bad he's gonna promote it's
gonna be all bad for us let's let let's
be clear here all bad for you I'm not
alright good game
okay we rollin one who's Justin there's
this risk Oh 20:58 how am I supposed to
play 2058 don't be fine oh yeah alright
alright sure we will where's Caleb I
mean you can always help me Caleb you
got the ball puppet engine see what it
no no Cheney here to chess club oh is it
against the rules oh yeah fine then yeah
that's cheating i attracted yeah we
can't do that although i'd like to we
can't oh he's playing the king's indian
well we got a new game oh and you're
you're playing the queen's game he was
playing the king's indian here are you
actually then please let me plays this
thing Nick no it's not Nick not Nick
although I played that okay yeah I
didn't I didn't mess that up quite yet
well Nick if you're if you ever get
tired of of doing stuff on you know
monitoring the chat you can always play
Perry he's he's called you out multiple
times
he must be busy doing something normally
he'd play and we're playing a 2058 this
if I can win this game would be my
greatest victory to date I'm just
curious
all the people out there who actually
how many people played the Queen's
Gambit
a lot of people play the Queen's game
see a lot of them do out of them it's
wondering what the statistic is I would
it was Danny Machuca would help me out a
little bit
he was too busy he used to call out some
moves for me from time to time you know
he used to for those of you who never
had seen Danny Machuca Danny mokuba's
behind the scenes he's our man he's
making everything happen he is making
this happen I wish I had the you know
the the huevos I wish I had a you know
the power to actually pick up one of
these cameras and go the back things
show what he looks like
no but he's uh think we're gonna lose a
pond you're losing him you do same pond
again
yeah and we're playing a 2058 for
heaven's sakes
oh this for me all this crap about I'm
playing 2068 I need to go up a pond
Perry go up you want to play one see I
just want to see you go along oh I'd
love to go home pawn against this 2058
believe me now are this guys being
threatened so we don't want that hanging
in there only down a pond know if you
have any if any viewers have any
suggestions of moves please let us know
just so you're just so we're clear on
everything there's a cat 10-second delay
before there's a second delay between
like what what they see and what and
what we see so if you get your
suggestion in too late can't use it so
get them in right now any sacrifices you
see I like some sacrifices
thank you some in intense chest I'll
sacrifice something I have I have some
ideas I have an idea
he's threatening my stuff
threatening my stuff
well let's get you you know I feel like
sometimes you're too focused on the game
you're not doing so focused on the game
there is something such as to focus on
anyway so let's let's say there's a
thousand points higher than I am then
are you telling me I'm too focused yeah
you know a thousand points why did I
Einstein work at you know a clerks as a
clerk at an office I don't know I said
there are certain you just need not to
think about something and then BOOM
idea happens no so let's let's we can
talk about something else to get your
mind off of this can't we
what do you think about the world open
the world opening what's the world
opener is out of chess there's our chess
match or chess tournaments yes it is yes
it is the world open I didn't know there
was such a thing whatever now we're down
to pawns or this just for feed a World
Cup that's just fantastic
what's it the world open world cup oh
the world cup okay okay so I heard isn't
I breaks the world cup
well is that true uh well my boy ding
ding when you're in number one China
just just lost just ain't lost being
lost to who but let's not talk about
that it's kind of sad so that's uh who d
lose to what is this rotten
raja baath good job man good job
shoutout to you why don't we do this
another shout out to the Midwest
Collegiate Chess Championship that's
going on right now in Columbia at
University of missouri-columbia I
believe today was day 1 of that
tournament and it's going pretty smooth
there is a brand new chess team this
year at Columbia coached by GM
in gorilla and we're looking to see some
good results now back to the Perry's
game forgets just 2058 yeah you don't
have to always say you know it's a game
it looks like you're losing to PI to
pause again
alright pom majority on on the 8a B file
okay well good job wherever this person
is good job not quite giving up quite
yet
that's the spirit never give up or is
that kind of like one of the
old-fashioned American sayings you know
I'm like as long as you tried your
hardest
everything's fine that's not true by the
way guys in real life participation
Awards don't matter
it's basically you win where you lose
Danny Machuca just asked what happens if
we draw well you know what they say you
can learn more about losing than you can
about worrying about drawing and winning
so I guess in the long run
losing is better so you can learn more
things losing is not better losing is
not better all right so I take it back
if you were a kid in the amateur little
levels losing might be better because
you can learn more however if you're
trying to just gain points drawing is I
guess technically better thanks Barry
thanks now do you feel like you're more
yeah yep I got you yeah yeah I don't
know if you guys can actually hear this
but Danny Machuca in the bag is actually
yelling out moves he's not yelling out
moves he's not yelling but we're in
trouble here we're losing another pawn
because he's bearing down on me right
here
stupid stupid Nick Bristol said just
playing fast and bad chest today how do
you want to respond to that guy oh I
don't know but I'm getting cheque and
losing it
sure oh I just lost my rook to the pain
because I got distracted well that's
your fault
that is my fault and we were up on time
but he's just too good okay
good game maybe week five challenges me
play someone closer to my love there was
these people well there was somebody
that says try to take East six but
here's chess tournament second delay all
right here's a swarm
here's risk oh-oh riscos Briscoe riscos
the long awaited long awaited risk Oh
after being called out a couple times
now he's in for anybody who doesn't know
who Nick risco is he is also a chess
associate here the same was Jessica is
it means the head librarian
he's the head librarian and he's a
personally good friend of mine yep he's
a pretty nice guy he's a good kid
sometimes he can sound sometimes he can
brag a little too too much but you know
that's just part of life that's part of
life
okay now what
Oh pin it to win it that's what Jonathan
says maybe that pen
let's play here Oh taking back with the
b-pawn instead okay okay all right
always be a nice feather feather in my
calf I can beatnik grisco mister 1956
haunting again tell not taunting that's
straight up that's a straight up hon
you're like God be nice if I could what
you saying is he chat he's playing he's
not chatting they are there somebody
does just ask same is chess club is the
only five-minute and under games that we
can challenge in the end yes yes yes
5-minute and under you know if we play
anymore longer than that that means not
many people get to play and we want as
many people to experience as possible
that's right that's right
if you ever if anybody ever feels we
should change that please let us know
let us know you know email for me I'd
love to pay like a 20 minute game but I
don't think my uh yeah that would be bad
yeah am I am I get boring for some
people but if you have any any other
suggestions for any other shows info at
Chet's aimless chess club org everything
oh and let's talk about our what about
these tournaments coming up Tony
oh we have what the national chess day
coming up right that's the 12th right so
we have in so earlier Perry explained
about the Friday action quads that are
going on every Friday and that's that'll
be today at 7:00 it's every Friday at
7:00 if you want join us the tournaments
that are happening within the next week
is Saturday October 12 which is national
chess day
so here the stainless chess club we have
the $1,000 national chess state
tournament guaranteed a $1,000 prize
fund so if you want to earn some money
that's a great chance to do it free
entry for grandmasters and international
masters so if you're one of if you
qualify one of those please come play
for free I'm sure people love to play
higher skill levels also the week after
that on the 19th and 20th there
is also a tournament
let me check them make sure I have the
right time I go on here is that is that
what it is let me pull this up just make
sure I don't make any mistakes oh okay
so Saturday October 19th here is the
Saturday night special that is I think
that's a pretty on pretty regular
tournament that gets held a lot it is
quick rated it's a four round Swiss game
in 15 close to second increment there's
four rounds to that entry fee 25 bucks
$1,800 unconditionally guaranteed so
somebody will definitely go home with
some money and I'm also free for GM's
and I am so if you are one of those
please swing by that following Sunday
October 20th is Sunday 6 players Swiss
also a pretty regular tournament here at
the Chess Club
it is also quick rated three rounds
twist game a 15 + 2 second increment
quick ratings will be used to for
pairings and stuff so it's only $10 in
entry fee which also means the price one
is slightly lower but it is quick rated
it's only 3 rounds it's fun so come and
try your hand on winning some of this
and that is basically all the open
tournaments here at the club in October
and then come Thanksgiving is all the
big ones thanks gave me open this one of
the year's Thanksgiving open we
basically have what three or four big
club tournaments every year Thanksgiving
open is one of them it's usually the
biggest one it is I think we usually we
always get over a hundred oh my gosh
like why should I think was like a
hundred and thirty people yeah there is
limited space here and I think it's
capped at 125 people so if you want to
play early registration is pretty much
key to make sure you get a spot also
lower entry fee if you pre-register
before let's see what Zetas before he 11
20 seconds oh did he
no he didn't he's playing so good in
risk oh he's playing good oh one quick
team one quick thing $10,000 guaranteed
prize funds for things gave me open if
you want to try your hand at that one
all right what about any scholastic
tournaments coming up Tony
it's classic tournaments there is one we
have an open squat sermon every month
it's open to any students in grades K
through 12 beginner to advanced alike
we have different sections and that is
actually the next one is actually
October 12th also on national chess day
it is also beginning of the Grand Prix
for those who you know who don't know
who that is it's a in our scholastic
tournaments from October to April every
month those seven tournaments count as
the Grand Prix tournament and you rack
up points based on how you do in every
turn where you play it in a year there's
big prizes for top players so that's
starting next month on the 12th please
visit our website so you lose chess club
org to check out all the things that are
going on it's pretty fun pretty fun yeah
we just have to move fast
how's Nick doing is he still playing yes
let's see here Nick you are doing well
up on time up on position Perry he's
doing well he's playing with 1956 okay
pairing suited Perry's doing pretty well
too I think he needs a little validation
right now so cool not a problem not a
problem what's he doing this can you
fork oh he can know he can't fork me
I was not on don't get forked because
this is actually my first anything on
camera so oh that's not true
those of you who are watching the
Sinquefield cup where the rapid and
blitz a couple month months ago this guy
was actually the translator for
Grandmaster yeon-yi
he was so you know that was I did not
translate for ding because ding is
actually ding speaks in English quite
well actually he's just he's just shy
person so he's kind of quiet so he might
not tell from that but he speaks English
quite well at least he can get by
without a translator but yeah
professional translator pretty cool
pretty cool where you check lated every
time yeah we're gonna get checkmated yep
you're getting good job Rick good I mean
good job Nick sorry good job Nick good
job yeah check way to make a good job
props props yep I tried I don't wanna
get checkmater that's checkmate
yeah you can't there's anything to do
about it oh let it go let it go you want
to play one Tony job no I don't know I
don't want to let him check wait I mean
that's just uh like a cherry on top cuz
like he you called him out multiple
times alright yeah that's kind of gonna
play one mr. Tony no sir no sir I just
like to trash-talk trash-talking me I go
okay well I need to get a victory that's
actually what I that's actually what I
was brought in to do I was trash-talking
EKKO I was told Warren I didn't have to
play to I can say I can trash talk a lot
so what's the chat going on are they
gonna know they giving me a lot of
trouble they're not it's actually uh
it's it's okay today
somebody has somebody's trying to talk
to Nick risco while he's playing because
last week they were being very mean Oh
Nick said not gonna lie I think Perry
had me in the opening so nobody said
Barry yep very very humble of you mr.
Chris Cody he's a humble young man
he's a good person yeah very humble for
for his age yeah but he can talk some
trash about chess but you know other
than that
of course he can I just hope that he we
talked trash up you know all the time
that's actually where I get a lot of my
stuff this is my trash talking course
the only way to get better is to
practice you know you wanted to practice
that with somebody I just you know this
blitz thing is not my forte a more
better at classical chess but I'm trying
to improve you got to be trying to the
words of a grandmaster I don't know
which grandmaster you have to be good at
all time I'll say all Torico being say
that I want to say yes but I'm not
entirely sure so maybe maybe I don't
know how many kids there are watching
this there's a lot I hope so we have two
we have 23 23 people oh my gosh 23 if
you are so there's this something in
lucky we don't know so we at the same
with chess club have just started a
training program for kids called select
chess program we have basically about 20
pretty high rated kids that were the
goal was basically to get them to be
title players
really mmm-hmm how's that going that's
going very well we started the first
semester was this we started in
September so this is actually just one
month in right now everybody's classes
are going well they're all playing
tournaments they're doing well in
tournaments so can't ask for anything
more
we'll keep track of how that goes for
any of you kids out there that want to
apply there are certain restrictions
that you need to certain requirements
you need to meet before you do that also
visit our website st. Louis chess club
org you can find anything anything you
need on there let's see how you're doing
still dolphin is so nervous yeah for all
of you chest noobs out there they were
trying to do everything we can't control
the middle develop I'm trying is already
castled but he's got pin going on here I
got this pin going on
but like I said I'm just trying to do
the best moves here I've been playing
chess about two and a half years so
fortunately working here I've got to
improve a little bit in the last two and
a half years there's this gentleman
that's saying only a way of getting
better at trash-talking is trash-talking
agreed that's what we've been talking
that's what we talked about
practice makes perfect right agreed
which I take with Danny my pawn why do
you trust me he shouldn't trust me he's
so cocky you are so kind
by taking that with a bomb well listen
you know this is kind of solid rook us
you know Bishop and pawn like that is
usually pretty solid yeah I feel like
he's gonna drag a dish of away pretty
soon well don't give any suggestions
teach it you can hear you if you're
taking my suggestions you're not playing
so don't go that route but see ya
he says take with the knight obvious
obviously he didn't take with the Nigel
I didn't want to take with the night
because then you know I just didn't not
want to take with the night yeah I think
the I think my my my suggestion was take
with the Bishop but you know like I said
don't listen to me I gotta get I gotta
get out of this pin though I need he got
his pin
so he did drive your bishop away he did
and I didn't want to mess with it so I
just I just took the night cool but I
wanted to break that pin so so how many
pawn islands does he have and I have I
have one two three so does he one two
three he has one two three yes three so
where's his weak his weak squares right
here and this gentleman also swear how
do you say a a three will force you to
trade your Bishop for the night which
happened yep good call good call trying
is the first step to failure the lesson
is never try just do that's that's a
yeah that's isn't that what it's not
part of a slogan for Nike like just do
it yeah I guess I partly i guess i
partly agree with that you know do what
Oh
GM Feingold said that so I trust the
jambs words you know go go with that go
with that
Nick says good luck Perry I have to get
to the club come on you got it
oh so he's give me encouragement what a
nice guy don't a nice guy whether he
means that or not that's a different
story but he said it so that counts
you know I figured that there will be
more people giving you advice on what to
do I don't really see yellow so I see a
lot just like random chatting
what are they saying just like some
people are trying to talk to other
people that's on this chat that's
they're not even maybe there but they're
not being like me nauseous
no they're vicious last week absolutely
vicious so this guy said PS winners 720
is my username and been wanting for a
game waiting for a game so you want okay
what does username PS winners 727 we're
gonna get to you we're gonna get to you
don't worry I just hope you don't I just
hope you don't regret it this guy's the
longer he plays the better he gets he's
like you know a rising air airplane he's
just going up always no checkmating
possibility is there the longer I played
the better I get maybe and this other
guy says dark senpai is mine I've
waiting for a game as well we'll get to
you too long time to go man get to get
to everybody I was gonna trade because
we're up on time Oh dark Sam has a
common guest on our show I was been told
by our producer danny Machuca thank you
for the patronage welcome back we will
definitely play you here's an here's a
piece of advice from one of our viewers
when explan I'm trying I'm trying really
hard
I'm really trying yeah don't do that
this guy DZ D sexy is that how you
pronounce it basically DZ EXI he wants a
game to everybody well everybody wants a
piece
get in line man get in line here we go
Donna duh you want something fair just
not fair siz not fair we could put on
some music if you want to get pumped up
gentlemen said should win this game
unless you blender right he's gonna try
to go here everybody on chat you should
have got the link two challenges so feel
free feel free
you're gonna play there I need to get my
yeah I mean so for all the challengers
so other people that want to challenge
us keep in mind that Perry is rated a
thousand had blitz so if you want to
play something with then that skill
level now's the time but if you just
want to have some fun come on in
we have a lot of employees here to the
Chess Club that's kind of watching this
it's kind of booing Perry it's kind of
funny they're booing me why are they
booing me what do you think why do you
think they're booing you because I want
to see you lose why they want to see me
lose lose see somebody lose it's always
more entertaining they singing somebody
win that's just yes life yes victory all
right yes yeah yes thank you very much
where's that 1 & 2 yes yes yeah all
right two whole points we got that's
right
whoever lost all right what's one for oh
my God look at all these all right who
wondered who was next to us complaining
PS winner 720 is a next one and then
dark senpai ps1 or 720 and then I don't
see him these X 3 or 720 ps1 or 720 if
you want to play you gotta you gotta
join in man let's play darks Empire I
play dark side by first dark for his PS
PS winter is 720 we had a winner game II
we can see you're on a litany Machuca
here we go yard senpai let's do it
oh we're playing my Sicilian playing my
Sicilian we're gonna play the night or
if this times I've been crushed with a
dragon up the ceiling here's a fun fact
I read somewhere that Sicilian is the
most played opening the most played
defense for black yep
against e4 that's actually I learned
that from Dani Machuca did you Danny
Machuca
I don't know if Danny actually ever
plays plays the people himself but he
doesn't play chess he doesn't please he
doesn't Danny Danny doesn't play chess
let's uh let's get used to play chess
yeah let's clarify that a little bit
Ryan Deering walking by Ryan Deering
come in come into the how you doing Ryan
grab a seat all right we have Ryan
Deering in the house one of my good
friends here how can you always use a
little support
grab a seat visible go grab one there we
go Danny you want to step in from the
camera for a second some people see
Danny
Danny's behind the scenes man Danny is
behind the scenes don't break anything
Ryan doesn't play anything on camera but
he is rated almost 2,000 Danny is an
excellent chess player right here yep
there is Ryan dear senpai you're
supposed to let us get set up first
before you make your move okay so what
Cillian did the nine or played a six
okay yeah it's my move what do we got
here so what do you think Ryan that's
alright that's alright so potentially
he's set up the Barack see mine he has
has me okay so that means that one of
her plans should be to play b5 but he's
got it covered
no no he doesn't does he I guess he does
what about bishop
well we got to play something cuz we're
running out of time all right so he
played Queen c2 signaling that he wants
to put a brook on the D file so it makes
sense for us to play Queen c7 Queen c7
alright sure alright why not
so now it has become Ryan Deering in
place the people know Terry Colson with
Ryan Deering as he's my helper what if I
played right here and our other other
staff members are continuing everybody
you know with this fantasy lose
one that is Jesse were complaining with
the head of our IT is software
development
he is booing us maybe maybe not
preparing off let's make that more
potentially threat that crook t8 yeah
somebody just said I want to play too
there there is but there is a link in
the chat lets you go to the place where
you can challenge us so please click on
that link now do we have b5 so it would
be five down no we don't somebody's
saying puts yes yes where's the link
again so please click the link we try to
get a chance to play us so okay does he
have any threats there's only about 20
minutes left 5 he might be what about
I'm not too worried about that
you know we push here no too much on it
do something correct it is Wii game in 5
minutes
not 3-2 game in 5 I know what kind of
bind it up here okay what if we played
ESET 5 then we surrender d5 and we're in
trouble
ok now let's go all the viewers are
there you do not have a choice in the
format right that's glitz five yeah
no way we can go 95 potentially open up
the D files ok liquidator backward pawn
ok f5 just just take it let's just take
it all right
that's right dark senpai how do you how
you feel how do you feel surprised doing
good Ryan's doing right now cuz you are
playing Ryan one of these player on that
I don't see fired right here do you
think oh that's right if he takes that's
right yeah I know that was good that was
good
looks like Perry is down a lot of times
a lot of times b3 Intermezzo so you just
have to anyway keep up not go down on
time and you'll pretty much win dark
some pie so uh I'll go ahead and give
you a early congratulations it's not
over yet now I have to move this guy
detailed an e7 dark senpai is a very
common spectator I'm sure he knows what
he's doing so we're gonna clean a5 yeah
he's gonna take my guy yeah night will
be even here soon
now hit him with me buddy with with b5
yeah oh he just hit you with b5 dark
somebody taking it yeah so this game is
gonna be over in a couple of minutes so
whoever wants to play please click the
link and try to challenge us the next in
line should be PS winners 720 if you're
actually on our list you will get to you
after that it's deck c DZ EXI so we'll
play that case so come on challenge us
come on challenges and then there's
actually a name I can't read so these
things this your book will try to get to
you this Bishop we're here oh my name is
jean jacques lacan we're gonna try to
get here that he's sick is that
b6 easy fast I'm sorry
ix yeah so if I mispronounce your name
I'm sorry
English is not my first language so it's
a little hard for me yep yep you got
time good game senpai
okay that's a mommy game good game rule
one in three the game okay
you know what next time I want to bring
one of those like papad casual games
remember you know all the will we are
the green do you suppose using playing
against um was he there
he has winners PS oh no were you there
if you were parry apologize I apologize
PS I apologize civilian yes the NIE Dorf
okay alright cuz I'm gonna get crushed
with the dragon all right
you play a six after dark senpai just
said thanks for the game duty okay good
job we thank you - if we're joining us
thank you for participating and then you
can play a five or a six right bull eos
keyhole with the e5 line is a little bit
more aggressive let's try it then
alright so are you that's a strange
choice is this let me see here
so this should be seven Bishop e6 then
we're gonna Castle kingside we should be
separate so it looks like this guy was
it and it's pretty solid here right MSHA
saucing is that name he sent out a
challenge a while ago we had to change
it cuz he thought he was 3/2 up PS PS
one winter said it it's okay it's okay
well we're gonna get to you we're gonna
get to you he's trying to take this guy
right he's played this very strangely I
don't want to take my bishop so Danny
Machuca we just leave it actually says I
have a chest adalah and I added you as a
friend can I challenge you via that yeah
okay he's gonna take his that possible
right he's gonna take it open up the F
file for a rug okay
alright actually the answer is yes in
the app there's I look to see a
something on the top right all right you
want to get another CH sometime right
yeah a little X is this to source that
you can challenge us with yes that you
can do that
I'm shopping it says 'if I've is on B
III and then he's six on bg7 smiley face
Playworks a to Queen cleaning to you
think
no no no he played Queen e2 Oh Queen he
said I'm gonna get my bishop I'm playing
right here okay
I would have jumped into the D force
well we'll play that back so potentially
that next potentially this game is gonna
be over in about six minutes so if you
want to challenge us so is he also what
there's a guy like what suppose that the
PHS winner is 720 ps1 or 720 is a guy
that you got a plate you should play
next okay ah somebody's singing hi
seeing the Chess Club hello hello hello
how's it going you stink I hope no it's
that guy after that I hope you are gonna
join us in a game if not feel free to
just wash around write commentary
I think we're fine I just like to say
that to me now freaking out a little bit
45 sometimes it's an idea it was likely
a good one
the question is d 5 what about D 5 and
Ryan said I came up with an idea I think
that's what when people say it's an idea
and usually mean it's like it kind of
sucks or you shouldn't play that why the
pause also take with the night but what
I could open the file but oh that's true
and I'm sure our structure is dominating
what makes a pawn structure healthy
ponch drugs it's two Center pogs there's
a little down the board
let's see this oh right so evil right of
course MSHA Steen he says sorry I'm not
there from the start we might know
Carrie but who and who are you basically
the guy on the computer I am onii-chan
I am part of the staff here at samos
chess club let's just take the night
just take them where you think yeah I
use this my first time doing this now
play for him now believe absolutely any
any suggestions let me know he was lost
bar sorrow also likes to play
alright bar so there's there's a link to
challenge us in this chat so he's got
one cook it and then we'll try to get to
you this one so once again it's only
game 5 minutes not three two game five
minutes he played here the plushie no
he's got square our first right let's
play Bishop c5 oh yeah let's identity
it's a weakness in this position nice to
meet you too Emma Shah Singh is actually
not Tommy
it's Tony tio and why clothes clothes
all right the link to challenges is up
again please click it on the chat and if
you want a shot at Perry actually at
this point is basically Ryan so Shawn my
challenge Ryan click the link he playing
together that's a plane together in
quotes play hey I needed some help I had
the first for five games by myself need
some help this is a team effort here at
the Chess Club yeah team effort so
everybody knows that we've never tried
to hide that yeah I would call a team
effort so if if Perry Perry's raided a
thousand and bliss wish it wasn't Ryan
1650 so we're gonna do the average of
that well that's about 12 say like a
1300 1300 1930 regular rate and I'm like
1325 regular rated so we just basically
call that even 1500 skill level overall
between the two this guy in action
you like him there let's just take a
moment here a viewer is saying Bishop CC
4 was better you win his bishop smiley
face really take a moment to appreciate
the beauty of our positions okay they're
keying out of any dangerous diagonals
these two have time to actually
appreciate their position which means
he's got which means their voices on
this undie 55 Ryan and we're running out
of time okay so yeah
so this guy's saying i'm bartek Oh Queen
we lose you're on the list man you're on
the list bar text we're gonna lose d5
next player should be okay play road
route cd8 trust me
rook see on d8 right here yeah all right
you see the traffic he takes on d5 yep
well now we gave the trap away though
well he hurt us now play someone like
this okay
good enough like this idea we can even
go this should be a seven we're still
putting pressure on I do then we can
play something like 97 95
all right so just to give you a heads up
on what's coming next period you're
playing ps1 or 720 all right first on
the list is Dec see if your which is DZ
X I that second I'll list if we can find
find you guys after we're done with this
game you'll be you two will be the first
two to get on on this then after that it
looks like we have shock shock makan
shock mark on try to go yeah to watch
the pawn yeah Dennis like that yeah
so it is what's this guy I'm playing
this way Bart X after that's Bart X
let's let's go with let's go with ìiî
ìiî just push this guy yeah all right
oh I like that Intermezzo take on it too
you think so yeah Dec see you are second
in line after PS winners 720
all right exit you're second in line
right three yeah bring your arms right
right here right so that we have a
gentleman here in the chat from st.
Louis asking if they can play 10th game
in ten minutes the answer is no you know
nobody gets any special consideration
its game in five no matter what all
right like I said if you want us to do
something please
Alessi please email us a nice chest
about that award we will consider it and
we might probably change it in the
future you had 92 we got it yeah mm
saucing what's your do it right is that
your your name in the as your for life
chess as well with this I will list my
man I'm sorry about that I forgot about
cheating sir you will be 42 you do e - d
4th of this right now okay deep move
your right right here you take over all
right
all right now it is officially now
Fagin's rice people playing that's
already in place I the first half you
can have the last last half yeah so we
probably only have game time for about
two more games so pious
what yeah oh it's a 90-minute show I'm
sorry I wasn't prepared for that the
others only have an hour so we have
playing time for everybody so I'm with
the nut flag strategy so strange so the
list right now we have to play PS winner
720 all right then taxi I'm gonna win
this shock makan your third I'm shopping
your for our tax your fifth
alright 720 all right we're just gonna
win this I'm just gonna win this
straight-up so shocked makan you are
third in line all right now yes now it's
long way to PS winners who whose bit was
cut off from Perry a while back I mean I
didn't get to play him so now it's
finally time PS winners
is this still perry place two people
where's Perry plays people right here PS
my winner is PS winners you this is a
hundred percent
yeah Perry playing you so my appointment
all right Rose is too bad
all right thanks for your help brother
thank you thanks Ryan appreciate it
appreciate it if anybody would actually
have Ryan plated people please he
contacts as well okay Oh me my computer
is about to die so I hope I have a cord
for free why is your computer dying no
hardware Danny yeah
all right so Dec see you're up next
after this game all right so be ready in
about eight minutes
yes then after Dexy is shocked makan
then MSHA singh then bart x
all right for anybody looks like we have
more and more people joining us in this
in this live stream for those of you who
have just joined us if you are wanting
to play against Perry Colson that's
right get your challenge click on the
link that says to challenge us and
that's where you do so and we are going
we have a list a waiting list of people
playing trying to older people yeah so
we will go by who basically comes first
as the Shore low lowest rating that's
what we're going by if you want to play
start a new account that's right and
then challenges that's what we're going
by the lowest rating possible I'm just
kidding I take on all comers that's
right that's right we are what's the
thing like where we are non
discriminating on discrimination non
discrimination everybody gets a shot
that's right as long as this within the
90-minute frame that's right they
haven't waiting longest okay
yeah we would try to go Connor we were
trying to play a first-come first-serve
try but they are there are people that's
kind of messaging us so we we might we
might put those people on top why don't
you send us a message if you want to
play maybe we'll put you higher on the
list no get some interaction going with
with us with a cultural date use your
brain use your brain now it's kind of
the scenario where you like if you're in
charge of a line you let your friends go
into first the kind of thing you know
okay send us a message if you want to
play but just so we're clear we're not
changing the format game in five stop
asking what do they want to play well
one person wants to play game 10 and a
lock you were asking me can we play
three three to answer is no game in five
we will consider changing it after we
get enough people wanting that so once
again info s st. Louis Chess Club org
everything is spelled out
how's it looking Tony what do you think
oh it's pretty solid take W up - no
don't do that
no no no I saw I saw almost blundered I
saw it man that wisely without a white
square bishop for white is just kind of
the entire entire board
it's pretty nice well JD stl would like
to play ok JD s yeah I would like to
play go ahead and challenge us we'll put
you on the list
oh look at this guy
he says I'm a low rated player lousy
player it will be beaten very quickly
don't mean I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
that well you are definitely Bart bar so
is that what's right what's your is that
your name on my chest as well
Oh Bart of Bart X I see it sorry Bart X
okay well you are right now a fourth on
the list so we'll definitely get get to
you so I need my stuff he's threatening
my stuff we're right now we're in the
the Chess Club is in it's time for Chess
Club is it like move some stuff around
so if you hear any noises into the mic
that's because Furniture is gaming room
moves around upstairs oh cool so that's
a good trade actually be be ready in
about four minutes good trade thanks dad
I won't all right I need to do something
but not that play here
play something borrow nothing is a
weight nothing is a wasted effort my man
you know sometimes it takes me longer to
scroll up and see everything so if you
were send us a reminder any time feel
free appreciate it a lot of stuff aren't
they yep you guys might not be able to
hear it but they're they're moving a lot
of stuff upstairs it's like screeching
you know furniture - all right Miss
Taylor Oh
checkmate good job girls winners good
job all right good job good job good job
all right all right well deck see you're
up next
all right so we're one in five so DZ EXI
who is this he is you next yep taxi taxi
taxi
all right there casual Oh Dex II can't
go casual taxi no captain okay everybody
know casual rated games only reading a
noob Frank and Chaka Chaka Khan Chaka
Khan Chaka Khan there we go
all right Chaka Khan all right Dec Dec
see we got a we're gonna wait on you
because you had a challenges with a
rated game you know casual games no
casual games at all rated games only so
Chaka Khan you're up first
he's up we still haven't lost our 2000
rating Tony PS winner says very good
game thank you thanks for the game
thanks for the beatdown appreciate it I
think I see I see it I see it very good
sportsmanship this is all she's saying
this is awesome if we were face to face
would be handshaking so that's right
this is awesome because that's what
chess is all about all right there we go
right here we got a phat makan yeah we
go we starting all right it's time for a
victory oh this this line is really
weird I don't know how to play this line
it's very strange
all right so Chaka Khan's playing sexy
if you challenge this with the rated
games you're up next
then it's M saucing and part X which
goes in the house risk oh thank goodness
we'll have a seat NIC everybody here
comes Nick risk oh the guy who'll take
over from Enix I have to go oh all right
well now it's officially Nick risk Oh
place two people you're down my time man
we're down on time so if a so shocked so
shocked makan uni other changes if you
need to change strategy do it now
there's a new person playing deck see
you got you got you
all right after this game we'll check it
out again you're an excellent I just
gonna make sure I don't hang anything so
for anybody who I've never met Nick
risco before here he is he was playing
parry about half an hour ago like I said
very very nice young young man he's the
one that I try to trash talk to a lot so
we can get some practice going this is
the guy who taught me everything I know
about chess so you hear that guys Noll I
hear that so if I lose this his fault
I'm not sure about that you're not
you're not at the level where like I
blame my teacher for everything well I
just gotta get to that level no I mean
you can you can get the height I think
you need to high school that way be like
my teacher didn't teach me that
suggestions Tony let me see here
[Music]
yeah we're actually getting bombarded
with noise just furniture moving from
upstairs it's kind of ridiculous all
right I think this shouldn't be too
terrible the idea is this guy yeah cuz
I'm doing math and it looks like we're
better are you good at math Nick Oh
decent decent would you get on your
let's say math section of the AC T SAT
33 Oh 33 out of 30 s is still one out -
36 - I know we change after my mine I'm
pretty old guys so you know everything
changed after I graduated high school
uh-oh boy did I mess up here I really
did just mess up here with the wrong
self omitting he messed up
also Chaka Khan go get it man go get it
oh boy it's one of those things where
you're like you know you had you you
have your foot on on his face you just
got to press down that's that's
basically what you say is really bad
alright let's say goodbye to our guy do
it man do it like you you you were like
you're on you're doing this already just
push press down a little harder press
out a little harder oh I mean yeah you
have you have a couple Center pants
that's you know that can possibly
probably do some yeah that's probably
all are we gonna ride on this guys
shucks shucks I'm hot
I like your I like your fish up pretty
nice pretty nice talking to our diagonal
love it I love it
where you to where you're rooks at man
bring it rooks out not talking in there
I'm gonna shock on press down press down
press down shop makan I'm gonna make
sure so a viewer is saying bit Bishop f6
Bishop f6 I don't want to trade pieces
when I'm down don't want to tray fees
when you're down I understand why
because you want to get it where'd that
Bishop you know it down pieces he's
doing like handy and I'm shocking is
saying chess happens chess happens it
does when you play fast and bad you have
to make sure you're not playing too fast
or too bad yeah I'm still figuring out
that balance so I don't know how many
viewers are actually in st. Louis but
you should actually come play - right
and I action cross tonight he might be
playing if you want to play him I will
not be playing oh he's not playing but
there are other people like you know all
the kids I was talking about you might
select chess group there are a majority
of them will be playing they range
anywhere between thirteen hundred to two
thousand so you probably get some of the
higher level ones I just like to welcome
Dennis assistant-manager Dennis Larew
walking into the room this is you you
don't get this chance very often he is
like one of those like he's like a
unicorn like you see him you're like you
gotta say hi if you don't you miss your
chance and you off to off your game I
really want to trade these guys well he
says no not now Bishop f6 when you
blender the piece Touche Touche
oh okay okay I don't know the position
off the top my head
well should we do you know how I was
talking to Perry lair about how we
should you shouldn't be to focus on the
chest I should talk about something else
so you get your mind off of it so you
can get a brilliant idea yeah you know
Albert Einstein work worked as a clerk
to get brilliant ideas ii i think you
know you can we can do that to you I'm
like not Albert Einstein but okay you
never know like some some methods work
on everywhere right so let's try all
right let's talk about this so uh okay
what do you know what do you know about
this mask
situation in Hong Hong Kong when you're
heard about that yet
no okay well I don't know how much
politics we can talk here so we're just
gonna go ahead and skip that part then
so I'm told that Danny Machuca the man
behind the scenes has very strong
opinions about that subject well Wade
puts a mic mic on and then we'll talk
about it but as for now I have you been
watching the Fifi day broke up I have
kept a few small tabs on it I hear this
ding guy lost yeah yeah my like I said
before my my boy ding waiting lost I
have a high hopes for that guy he just
won the Sinquefield Cup a couple months
ago here in st. Louis and I'm actually I
think he will be the world champion one
of these days you are entitled to your
own opinions you can no profanity I can
keep playing chess I think I have a
comeback here ladies and gentlemen
please welcome our you know what you're
the unicorn you can't just oh I know
what you're gonna say at one point down
this LaRue's trading floor was my scene
for those who did not hear are you
unicorn yell out the word weak to the
Nick it happened it happened I think I
have a comeback here uh saucing yes
there is about there is a lag between
chat and what you see I've been told us
about what's it 30 seconds so yes there
is okay oh the comeback is not gonna be
as great as I thought it alright Dexy
you have about two minutes before we get
to you so make sure you challenge us in
a Raider game okay you're next on the
list
checkmate after that and I'm saucing
you're up on the best o day Nick risco
pulled it out hey we need to pulled it
out talking about not chess oh yeah I'll
get to that one deck see hey this is
next
go down he had to switch a couple times
being right there okay here's the switch
got that Jackson you're up man
I'm shopping you're listening this
alright i'm saucing you have afterdeck C
and then Bart x10 JT STL oh I don't know
what to do here oh it's move one I'm
already right off the bat you are just
stunning this one g-force beyond me
well let's talk about something aside
from oh the guy you were just playing
soccer Shakman concept thanks for
playing oh yeah thanks for the game
thanks for all the shoutouts guys
appreciate it appreciate it
MSHA Singh says well done so good job
job I feel like I did well yeah we're
talking about oh yeah how do you feel
about this new Joker movie that's coming
out nice I've seen the previews I don't
know if I'm gonna go see it or not DC
has had interesting movie yeah career
I'm not I'm not gonna lie like when it
comes to the Joker the guy that played
the Joker in the bad name what's his
name they say he that guy passed away
that guy yeah I I like I like his
performance the best no I'm sure
whoever's playing the Joker now is gonna
be great
but like it's kind of fun no big shoes
to fill I remember I was having a
conversation with Dennis LaRue he was
telling me he was wanting to get a like
a straight razor and I told him no
because he's gonna get this sick
laceration on his face and come in
looking like the Joey J Touche
and sha singh said D for resign I
thought smiley face I really did think
about it
dark senpai is here waiting for Nick
darks I thought you already played my
man you were you your honor you're on
the list after everybody else not sure
if we can get to you but you're I'll put
you on the list again Heath Ledger good
thank you I'm Shaw saying Heath Ledger
thank you gentlemen
very I mean he was a talented actor died
very young but I think he was he was
great as Joker I don't know if yes
that's the best Joker ever I agree
although did you guys watch
that movie The Suicide Squad I'm not
even sure that was is all about Peters I
don't think it's just came to video I
was in theaters was it I think I think
but the Joker in that was actually
pretty pretty cool I don't think you're
better
was it yours Joe the laugh was pretty
cool
he only liked Nicholson okay okay I
think I can't be get behind that old
school I like it cool
I get behind that all right Tony I'm
gonna need some hand and brain here all
right let me pull all my in general
quick stock Fisher do right yeah yeah
what piece with stock fish move fast and
been let's say fish up - all right you
said Bishop e6 I don't know all right
cool oh wow I'm not calculating anything
just is too hard to calculate it's a
revolving door we have a bunch of chests
personality starting in today Bart
Marcel Mauss ro
no what do you mean you don't like
Batman movies dark I feel like that's
like the the path that everybody is
taken nowadays unless you know unless
you're like the the cartoon guy like
what's the point of not guys driving a
big Fork let's take care of that so this
guy heard that that joke new Joker movie
is a masterpiece
you know what master I'll probably go go
see it just to see what it's like but so
DC masterpiece and the new choker is
asana i its who play some new Joker is
it joking Phoenix okay I I believe it
he's a terrific actor too I believe it I
believe it let's take care of this guy
okay cool cool going and going for the
float that we're doing alright based off
of the conversation are you more of a DC
guy
compared to Marvel I if I had to pick
one actually I can't pick just one I
like them both I like em both okay four
so just a little background I I was born
in China grew up there for like you know
until I was like eight or nine and I
came here so I didn't have any Marvel or
DC contact before 1990 four or five so
and then when I got to to that point I
started watching it all reading all of
it and I'm a big fan of both so this is
an interesting move that's how I am
where does he go got make a move man
you're down on time down on time BEC see
you're doing great up a minute plus your
your positioning probably a little
better a little better I like it I like
it
I just keep shuffling stuff and hope my
opponent blunders
okay okay
do you screen just one little Tariq
what's going to be I don't know
hold on did you kick something I don't
think so no you're still plugged in
you're fine alright we'll see how it
goes
Marvel movies kind of suck but comics
are more entertaining than juicy oh oh
face it fix it is it fixed this may be
what's in this boy alright next see
we're going dark for a couple of seconds
oh gosh I can't see and I'm down on time
we good all right we're good we're good
we're good
sexy I thought you were gonna be a good
sportsman and let it let it right on you
you your time while we fix computer I
guess not no be decided to make a move I
mean I will say that as just as from a
player perspective that's the right move
because you want to win but you know
time I'll sportsmanship kid [ __ ] while
watching the show I mean it's only a
fair you just not play for it maybe like
a minute I would love a minute advantage
actually I think it would be very much
appreciate yeah by everyone involved
let's see here alright Marvel movies
kind of sucked but the comics are more
entertaining indeed DC alright I can get
behind that I can see how that happens
in the mood for love is a good Chinese
movie there are a lot of Chinese movies
nowadays that are basically just focus
on love conquers all you know kind of I
feel like that's a lot of movies
everywhere so it'd just be movies yeah
always
it's kind of little tired out if I want
a dark movie about terrorism then I
don't need fantasy world characters in
it that's true that's true have you guys
ever seen what is it Olympus has fallen
is fallen London has fallen that's just
like straight up darkness there's a
third one there there's the third movie
coming out it's a where is it it's like
is I think it's eight angel must be
angel has fallen right that the main
character is now like a bad guy to the
state we need whatever he's about rising
yeah yeah yeah I assume that you didn't
watch the last Avengers movie right I
did watch the last Avengers end game
where just like everybody's half the
world's dead and then something rise
back a rat saves the world that's how
you do it
alright I'm down a minute let's see he
says blindfold training blindfold
training yes I see somebody playing by
we can actually do a show about
blindfold chess if you wanted to that
Julian Pro League looks pretty good at
this blindfold here's here's what I need
everybody to do I need everybody who has
a suggestion to email to info as st.
Louis chess club org because one that
way we can actually show our bosses what
people actually want so we can change
things we act like we have power we
actually don't so you need to you know
like put it in words and submit it I
would appreciate it if my opponent
started working on their blindfold
training right about now yeah look at
this guy since there's a second delay we
don't know if you guys have any
technical problems how thirty seconds in
true true Touche you got me there Touche
it's not like we can warn you mm-hmm and
then another guy says like it man you
know who that is who it man
no I I so IP man ma n it man is theirs
he was a Chinese martial artist he's
actually Bruce Lee's master there's a
lot of there's well there's some there
was more than two movies there's I like
a five there's like five or six
different movies about him but like the
ones yeah so there's a couple on net I
don't know if they're still on Netflix
but it was a couple on Netflix and then
there's like other ones that are not
shown on Netflix but it's there's a he's
a famous martial artist that's been made
into movie many many times super focus
mode Bishop f8 yes so I know the idea if
I take this then Chuck and I take and I
lose my queen this isn't
I was talking with a screen shut off got
it got a blank oh that's why you said
blindfold it's because our screen shut
off so I gotcha now I get it now I get
it okay who's next
Hey next is M Shasti I'm sha singh
you're next yep I'm sha Singh you're up
next
you're an super folks smooth this is
right and after this game
Bart X you're up next so get ready Bart
X in about ten minutes yours
yeah dude there's a lot of movies on the
it man agreed agreed
I feel like unless you actually study
martial arts some point your life we're
actually are interested you don't know
who that is like this guy he doesn't
know who that is I don't know who that
is but one one of if not the most
I wouldn't say demos but like probably
in America he's the most famous one
because there's so many movies about him
but he's one of the most ones one of the
most famous ones so props unknowing on
what that is all right all right I'm sha
singh is started against Nick looks like
big [ __ ] dick has a big Center control
I'll know what's going on Tony that's uh
your your the player man I don't
I'm the colorful commentary I see yeah I
I learned the phrase colorful commentary
from anime I was watching this baseball
unit anime and some commentators are
like we have to one that gives the stats
and one that's the colorful guy so I'm
trying to be that guy I think it's
suiting you up
don't laugh Danny Machuca the anime was
called Kai when was this I believe there
was two big baseball anime that set that
uses that term one is major which is a
really old one because I'm old Wow
danny is saying he never saw a lot about
that even though he claims to be a big
anime guy that's that is my claim and
it's true oh he's saying I'm claiming
that he's a big anime he didn't click
claim it okay
alright noob I don't know what you guys
is problem is but I'm trying to play
chess game over here we go uh come on
Nick fast and bad move X I can only be
so fast and bad he can't when he click
so fast you know
alright here we go another person says
in my case if the interest comes from my
girlfriend that is Singaporean Chinese
therefore the interest in it man and
Xiao long ball which is Wow
which is basically little soup dumplings
that's cool that's cool I'm a big fan of
those two man and props that you
actually put Chinese characters on the
chat a lot of people you know don't do
that so props exe said well great game
had a hard time glad I won though yeah
yeah that was a very rough game actually
good good job on your game I also like
the fact that your your picture on your
profile is from an anime that's cool
that goes right along where we were
talking about Ace of Diamonds looks to
be that bad baseball you anime that
that's that's the current one yes ha
joke's on this guy I wanted to put my
rook on b1 anyway wow this this
gentleman this one over yours and there
was a lot by enemy too it looks like he
listed all the names that we were
talking about so that's a props props
you show Danny you definitely show Danny
that's that's like the most current
baseball are you on the mic right now
I'm like can can people hear you what
yeah you should watch it no it's not
like Prince it's not like so you know
like there are some anime shows then
I'll just go above and beyond to what
north of them like human physical
capabilities are like for example we
don't we're talking about that I know my
dad is that can correctly depict what
normal human movements are like like I
cannot I cannot create a tornado when
I'm playing tennis that's impossible
do you do you have a do you have a mic
on right now can people hear you know
okay we're gonna we're gonna put later
on well maybe next show we're gonna put
it on a mic on Danny Machuca so you hear
all the BS is coming out of mouth it's
ridiculous alright another another
viewing of the unicorn Dennis little
come on back here boy I don't hear this
is this gentleman is is the proclaimed
unicorn the scene was trust Bob you
don't you don't see him you don't see
him a lot but he is very important and
he is mythical
have you have you played play the people
is that have you been on this yeah for
everybody who's played Dennis before
whoa I'm sure you you lost
why is he okay taking them old school
Oliver tsubasa dude nobody has seen
Tsubasa salute I grew up I well I watch
that show in China back and I don't know
89 so I don't know if this is but it
looks like I just won material I'm how
do you a member is asking how do you
know how close we are in the queue of
challenging us the answer is we're going
by first-come first-serve but if you
message us on the chat I put you ahead
of the list and that's just one of the
things like you know we're friends I put
my friends on top of list that's how he
goes now right well that's how it goes
for this session if I'm not you're
completely different I'm okay sacking
upon because I'm looking
you're the best co-host this dream am I
the best co-host I believe her yeah
you're one of those guys colorful
commentary use the term correctly
I said animated how do you okay a
question is how do you explain there are
no American girls in the top 20 feed a
ranking oh okay
so you know as as the best chess club in
in America some say the world it's kind
of that's kind of like hitting below the
belt when you're asked how go and
there's no American girls in the top 20
come on man they're getting there
they're already there right right now
they're about nine years old so you
gotta give them time to get up there see
a part of it is just what they uh there
aren't as many females who play chess so
the outside Gotti's feeling to go and
here comes the hey listen here is the
feeling okay we got you got your twitch
rating performance coming up was that
supposed to mean I came to support those
of you are wondering how to do your job
correctly this is how you do it you you
you really killed a person if we would
major rating go lower ridicule right I
got like really my gosh rating you can
have knowledge yes it's still higher
than that is uh basically how a lot of
parents teach your kids if you lose you
suck can I get away with that I can yes
because it comes with check and then I
check again and I'm gonna be up a rook
let's see best co-host hands down thanks
bro
thanks appreciate it am I the co-host
for the co-host or me to not do do this
anymore but it's cool right you don't
think it's cool they watch you play
chess viewers but yours wait wait you
guys like to watch sub to 2000 players
play chess
we're trying to make Nick look bad
because as he got our Chess Club rating
below two thousand so it's kind of sad
I'm working on it I'm working on it I
don't know why I'm not pushing stuff I
forgot how to play chess all right let's
not talk about anybody's dance family
members all right let's not do that the
guy with the hat you know who you are
what okay
that fortress's don't exist I just don't
know how to play this game so this guy
wants you to accept a challenge from I
don't know the rules 69 you are on the
list my fir'd that name before on the
list
you are on the list after Bart Bart X
and JD s so I'm not even sure when they
get get to you right now because we're
almost like is that right or a long time
so we will try to get you there but you
were third on the list bro
oh he wants to ask me do you know that
lower rated players are better at
coaches I am actually curious about this
because Christian Carrillo is fabi's
coach so I don't I don't know if I agree
about that a hundred percent but like
some people who are not higher rated can
teach better and can do things better
but I think if your dual combo of can
teach and are higher rated that's like
there's a settle for a draw here selling
for a draw I know I was winning and then
I couldn't find the thing I was too late
in finding the idea well he's going for
a draw is their jaw it's already it's
already drop all right Bart do you have
time for their game is this we have time
for Bart okay Bart Bart X part X is up
part X okay Laura telling this bar
tracks you were my friend is the last
one yes I think this is going to be the
last all right Bart X you were the last
player JDS STL will try to get to you
some other time and
the guy who art who was just morning to
get in you're out of time but Bart Bart
tax you're asking make it count
make it count he's playing the caro-kann
he's not making it count
Oh trash hockey mediately from Nick
begin to the game you're playing the
Carroll con you suck
Danny's laughing so I know I have some
sort of approval and I'm tossing saying
the game you played great thank you
thanks for the game that was a fun one
interesting end game I'm gonna have to
look at it again
we're definitely have to look at it
we'll probably put that in one of our
classes so they can make make fun of
Nick more yes then I was on then I had a
rook and I couldn't couldn't do it but
John that's a great broadcast this oh
thank you thank you
try to make them good what so I don't
know the rules sick wait I don't know
the rule 69 we'll have to do this some
other time because you were Bart X will
be the last game today what I know what
I like I will challenge in the next
screen next stream then by the way I'm
two and OH against Perry I like the fact
that you won twice I'm not sure if like
bragging winning against Perry is kind
of a thing to do but don't go cool
I just lost upon but I have big center
big center by Nick risk Oh big center I
should probably start caring about games
more so how do you feel about all these
emojis popping up in the chat it's kind
of like great gray schoolgirl girlish
don't you think no comment
sorry I'm just I don't know
so he says when you some guy says when
you mix anime and chess in the same
broadcast it has to be the best
broadcast my man you get us you know you
should check out the chess web stream is
well known because they do a lot of that
yeah yeah it's our gyms Dennis Boros
Elia nice Nick and I can't remember the
third guy he's not on there as much you
mean everybody who plays chess you kind
of know that she has community those
kind
hand-in-hand we're all nerd we're all
nerds here let's just be proud of it and
so I'm hurt so Danny Huachuca is saying
chess anime in the works can't wait to
watch that if you guys ever watched
Hikaru no go about go we're gonna try to
do something about chess so that that
show actually made Danny play go for a
couple years they actually made me start
learning I never played it cuz I was
like it's too were you any good Danny
can i sack stuff
AGG Magnum mater ER is working on a
chest manga looking forward to it
looking forward to it
you guys probably don't know this but
our unicorn Dennis LaRue is actually
quite illustrative himself I seen a
couple was drawing this is pretty pretty
a pretty bad bad a can't can't say you
know no no my job sanity here so no it
was pretty scribe this is pretty good at
it what am i doing nick is kind of going
off on himself just plain bad moves and
I'm playing them slowly so looks like
you guys have the same time control
there same same time left we have next
night has very bad spots to go to which
one both of them all right this is this
all right it's gonna shake it off recoup
I thought you were gonna go the other
way that's cool
I haven't been watching this from
actually for a long time two weeks but
this is the most interesting broadcast
did anybody else notice I missed meetin
thanks man
thanks man if you guys have if you guys
notice Nick miss the mating - but I
found it please chat please chatez
please cut in the chat
Nick you suck yeah make fun of me for
missing matin - I need it for all right
for anybody who thinks this is very
interesting
please review us at info as English
chess board Tony Chen put that name in
there dude I want to raise come on put
my name in there is so hopefully you can
join us not in two weeks time but pretty
much every single day we have this
Tuesday through Friday we do Tuesdays
are at noon is that correct Annie yep
Tuesday already at noon but Wednesday
Thursday Friday at 3 p.m.
I'm sure we can make something work to
where it's already fun to watch so
anyways that is it for our games yeah
I'm good job artex good job for anybody
who was on a wait list and not get to
play we'll see you next time thank you
for stopping tonight thank you very much